the premise of the movie is set during
the time of the great depression it is a
time when people die to get a job and
make money the societal condition is not
ideal but lucky for the protagonist paul
he is a guard in the state prison of
louisiana the prison consists of death
row cells referred to as the green mile
paul is in charge of the criminals who
are sentenced to death for the past year
he has been having trouble at work
because of a bladder infection he has to
frequently take medicines to reduce pain
and can hardly pee because of it his
fellow guards are all kind people except
for a pretentious man named percy he was
appointed to the force because of his
father's connections and shows his
incompetence every chance he gets he
treats the inmates like animals and
shows no respect for his seniors one
afternoon percy brings in a criminal
named john coffey and makes a show out
of the guy calling him a dead man his
colleague psy annoyed by his obnoxious
personality the criminal john is giant
compared to the guards but is quiet and
submissive paul is amazed that a
muscular man like him is worried the
lights will go off at night because he
is scared of the dark before he leaves
jon puts his hand forward and shakes
paul's hand something that no other
criminal has ever done the guard is so
intrigued that he does some digging and
finds out why jon was sent to jail last
month two girls were kidnapped from
their backyard when the father found out
he and the people from the village
organized a search party jon was found
crying hysterically while holding the
dead bodies of the little girls he was
accused of assaulting the girls and
killing them and since there was no
evidence to prove otherwise he was
convicted later paul is outside when he
meets the prison warden hal morris hal
reveals that percy has applied for an
administrator job at a mental hospital
which would mean better pay and better
hours the news is exciting for paul
because he and his co-workers are tired
of cleaning up after percy's mass the
warden also mentions that his wife
melinda is not doing good she suffers
from a lethal brain tumor which has put
her on her deathbed hal is constantly
worried for her and he feels helpless
that he cannot save her at night paul
talks to his wife and tells her about
jon he also apologizes that he can no
longer make love because of the
excruciating pain caused by the bladder
infection his wife wants him to go see
the doctor but paul is almost ashamed to
have gotten the disease the following
day one of the guards named brutus sees
a mouse in the cell block they try to
catch it but it runs into a padded
storeroom afraid that it will eat away
the floor they clean up the entire room
to look for it but strangely enough the
mouse is missing a few hours later percy
spots the mouse and goes into a fury
trying to kill it the mouse goes back
into the storeroom making percy clean
the room as the others did earlier the
guards don't tell him they already tried
that and watch him lose his mind over
the missing mouse paul berates him for
making a fuss out of nothing which
results in percy being disrespectful to
him and his friends he threatens to use
his connections to fire all of them from
their jobs paul retaliates that if he
ever makes such a threat again they will
teach him a lesson even at the cost of
their jobs in the following scene paul
and the others are preparing the
electric chair for an upcoming execution
the most important part of the execution
is putting a wet sponge on the convict's
head before the cap is attached if the
sponge is removed the person will
struggle before his death but if it
remains the electric current will go
straight through the head and the
execution will go smoothly later at
night brutus leads the criminal's
execution paul knows that percy was
waiting to witness an execution before
transferring to another job when
confronted about this percy reveals that
he doesn't just want to witness one but
is looking to be in charge of an
inmate's execution in the following
scene one of the inmates named dell
finds the mouse again and names it mr
jingles he is amazed by the animal's
intelligence because it can fetch a
spool of thread as a trick the guards
allow dell to keep mr jingles as a pet
since it does them no harm then we see
paul meet ward and hal again this time
the warden is worried about a new inmate
being admitted to the prison today his
name is wild bill a sociopath who killed
three people in a holdup he is
aggressive and evil so the guards will
have to be extra careful while handling
him unfortunately for paul that day the
bladder infection makes him suffer so
much that he can hardly pay attention to
his surroundings two guards bring the
murderer bill to the prison he pretends
to be in a trance and then makes an
attack on them they try their best to
restrain him but the man hits paul in
the groin multiplying the pain he was
already enduring similarly another guard
is nearly strangled and the only one who
can stop him is percy he is right behind
the murderer with a full view of him but
he freezes in terror and can do nothing
finally brutus comes in and takes the
murderer out when the others bring him
to the cell paul is left behind and
collapses in pain jon sees this and asks
him to come closer because of an
emergency even in great pain paul goes
to him only to be grabbed john puts his
hand on his crotch and does something
that causes the pain to disappear in an
instant i've heard of this trick
somewhere upon letting go the inmate is
weak because the pain paul was enduring
has transferred to him seconds later a
cloud of nat like spores fly out of his
mouth and he goes back to normal a
shocked paul asks him what happened to
which john only says that he helped in
reality he sucked the disease out of
paul and suffered himself but then the
disease flew out of his body as spores
after the process john is exhausted he
goes to sleep while paul goes to pee to
his surprise he feels no pain at all at
night he returns home and makes love to
his wife because of the incident paul
has grown more interested in john and
his story he goes to john's public
defender to inquire more about the man
according to paul such a childlike
innocent man must not have committed the
crimes but the defender thinks otherwise
paul also finds out that no one knows
where jon came from because the first
time he was seen was with the girls dead
bodies the next day paul gives john a
loaf of cornbread thanking him for his
help jon shares the gift with dell and
mr jingles while bill throws racist
remarks at him for the next few days he
causes a lot of trouble spitting at
people urinating wherever he likes and
disrespecting the guards having had
enough of his insults the guards wrap
him up in a straight jacket and lock him
in the padded room in the meantime the
day of dell's execution is nearing he is
not afraid of dying but is worried that
mr jingles will be killed after his
death brutus promises to send the rodent
to a place called mouseville in florida
where he can work in the theater later
that day bill is put back into his cell
but he doesn't wait before causing more
trouble he grabs percy and touches him
inappropriately percy is soon let free
but he wets himself in the process
everyone decides to never speak of the
humiliation again but percy hears dell
snickering hence when he comes across mr
jingles that day he stomps on him and
kills him dell is heartbroken and feels
like his child was killed the guards
cannot do anything about it but jon asks
paul to bring mr jingles closer he blows
into his palms and resurrects the animal
from the dead everyone is shocked and
dell couldn't be more grateful the
execution day finally comes and percy is
put in charge of it paul hopes that
after killing dell he will finally
transfer to another job dell is placed
on the chair in front of the audience
and percy starts the execution he hooks
del up to the electrodes and purposely
does not soak the sponge which is then
placed on dell's head this causes the
poor man to struggle and scream in pain
simultaneously jon also cries as he
channels dull's struggles into his own
body in the end del lights on fire and
his life finally ends afterward percy
claims that he didn't know that the
sponge needed to be wet a furious brutus
punches him at the obvious lie he has to
be held back to ensure he doesn't kill
the man as a result of the incident
percy is forced to take an immediate
transfer to his new job at the mental
institution surely he'll be nicer to
people there paul then goes to john and
finds out that he tried his best to use
his powers to help dell however even
after suffering so much pain he wasn't
able to save him moreover the pain was
also felt by mr jingles who has since
run away in the following scene paul and
the other guards are having a meal
together he has just been to the
warden's house and seen the trouble he
is going through his wife melinda is
losing her memory and becoming violent
as a result of the tumor but the man can
do nothing about it hence the guards
decide to bring jon to the warden's
house to help melinda but they have to
do it in secret since they can be
punished for letting a murderer out of
prison the next day they put the plan
into action and knock bill out using a
drugged glass of beer they also gag
percy put him in the straitjacket and
lock him inside the padded room so he
won't tell the authorities when jon is
told about the plan he is excited that
he gets to help someone before his death
it further makes the guards realize how
good of a man he is however on their way
out ben who is still conscious grabs
jon's arm for some reason jon is
terrified of the man but is let go when
he finally falls asleep outside jon
jumps in excitement to be able to see
the sky and the ground upon arriving at
the house they are caught by the warden
and paul has to explain what they want
to do although the warden doesn't
believe that a murderer like jon
possesses any power he allows them to
meet his wife jon gets very close to
melinda's face and sucks something out
of her mouth as a result the house
starts to shake and the lights shine
intensely seconds later he falls down
and starts coughing and simultaneously
melinda sits up she is healthy and has
no memory of anything that has happened
since the diagnosis this time john is
unable to free the spores so the disease
is confined within him suddenly melinda
stands up and recognizes him she says
that she met him in the dark and that he
gave her his light she doesn't
understand what happened but knows that
jon saved her life somehow before
leaving he is given a necklace as a
thank you present that will surely make
him feel better about being executed
back in prison percy is let free from
the padded room as he leaves jon grabs
him through the bars and releases the
spores directly into his mouth the
disease transfers to percy and makes him
hallucinate as it did to melinda he
walks in front of bill's cell and
empties his revolver into his chest when
the other guards catch percy he releases
spores from his mouth upon being asked
why he did this jon sticks out his hand
and paul takes it this makes him see
that bill was the one who abducted the
little girls who john was accused of
killing jon knew there was no way of
redemption for the killer which is why
he killed him later the police arrived
to investigate the death percy is
questioned but appears to be in a
catatonic state he is declared unfit to
be on duty and is sent to a mental
hospital ironically the same place he
was supposed to transfer to meanwhile
the day of jon's execution nears now
that paul knows he is innocent he
doesn't know what he should do his wife
senses his dilemma and suggests he
talked to john to see what he wants in
the following scene jon reveals that he
doesn't want to live anymore he can feel
the pain of all the others around him
which is a blessing and a curse at the
same time he does not want to feel the
pain anymore and is tired of hearing
everyone's thoughts about johnny depp
and amber heard so executing him would
be the greatest act of mercy done upon
him as a last request jon says he wants
to watch a movie on the day of the
execution jon is taken to the auditorium
in front of the audience they berate him
calling him a murderer and a molester
however the guard's reaction is the
opposite as they watch him get strapped
in tears paul goes to put a cloth over
his face but jon says that he is afraid
of the dark in the end the poor man is
electrocuted and killed the scene
changes to several years later paul is
grown old and lives in an old age home
consisting of many retirees no one is
allowed to go outside since they are
prone to get lost but paul takes long
morning walks every day he goes to a
secluded cabin in the woods and watches
someone inside one afternoon the
retirees are watching an old movie on
the tv it is the same one that jon
watched as his last wish it brings back
memories to paul overwhelming him with
emotions he walks aside and tells the
story to a fellow retiree elaine he and
the other guards were transferred to a
youth corrections facility after john's
death unable to watch any more
executions later that day paul brings
her on a walk to a cabin in the woods
they see a mouse living inside the cabin
which turns out to be mr jingles when
the animal felt the pain at dale's
execution it gained some of john's power
and has been living ever since similarly
paul is also 108 years old and in good
health this is because a fraction of
john's power was transferred to him when
they held hands to find out the truth
about the murders paul has watched all
his loved ones die and feels like this
is his punishment for killing a man like
john in the last scene paul is seen at
elaine's funeral he has yet again
outlived a loved one subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching